[Music]
myself and my two colleagues Dave and
Monza I'm going to talk you through a
few different aspects of Google's
Network and why we think it makes for a
high performance network my section is
going to be taking you through the
basics the underlying physical and
operating aspects of Google Google's
network that sort of powers Google Cloud
I'm gonna talk a little bit how we plan
to build our network for resilience how
we operate in a resilient fashion and
also how we extend this thinking beyond
the boundaries of our own network to the
Internet in general so let's start off
it's possibly no surprise that Google
owns and operates and is built probably
one of the largest networks in the world
this network is primarily based on fiber
that we've lit ourselves or we've even
built ourselves or in conjunction with
partners now what this means is that we
can offer a predictable and resilient
performance level all across the world
so if we look at the map you can see
here these are all the network paths
that we've built over the twenty or so
years that Google's been running
highlighted as well here we have some of
our major submarine cable investments
dating back to 2010 with unity all the
way through to the more recently
announced cables that are coming on
stream in the coming year so this is the
network that enables us to serve
billions of search query answers this is
the network that enables us to serve
billions of hours of YouTube videos to
users all over the world and this is
also the network that Google uses to
replicate content and services between
our custom-built data centers and our
footprint again across the world and
critically it's the network that powers
Google clout
now in recent years what's interesting
and exciting for us in the cloud team is
that it's our cloud customers and some
of their demands that they've started to
shape the nature of our network
investments and network planning as we
go to new locations with new mini
clusters and new cloud regions and as we
have to think careful about how we
connect in ways that prioritize maybe
latency over resilience let me give you
an example of that this is last year and
you'll see here that when we built some
new paths between Singapore our
Southeast Asia region and Sydney we
almost cut our latency in half it's
actually not possible to get that much
shorter latency now between these two
locations okay this is a great example
of where we've said latency is important
resilience is important let's build more
capacity that makes sense for our cloud
users and we're doubling down in this
region later this year we will have two
new cable investments the Indigo cable
and the JGA cable coming on stream to
add even more capacity and more
performance what's also interesting to
think about is that Google is now at a
scale in its operations that it can go
about planning and building submarine
cables by itself what this means is that
we can provide a level of path certainty
we can lay the cable where we need it to
go to connect our locations that make
sense for Google and for cloud and we
can do it an awful lot faster than
traditional approaches where you're
working with many consortium partners so
these things are called private cables
in the industry parlance if you want to
read a little bit more about some
private cables that we've announced
encourage you to use your favorite
search engine and look up the fury cable
which is going from Chile up the west
coast into North America or the Dunant
cable which there was a press release
about some exciting technology Dave will
talk about just last week but the Dunant
cable goes between Fran
and America as well and these are
private cable systems Google's building
by itself and we're able to do that
because of our scale now the great news
for all of you here is Google cloud
customers is that you're able to connect
to this network at a hundred and
thirty-four locations all around the
world that could be directly or through
an extensive network of cloud
interconnect partners it has never been
easier to get onboard our global network
now it's great having a huge network but
as our traffic grows and we build new
cloud regions and we have to build new
paths for new capacity it's also
critical that we maintain and improve
the performance of the network now when
we're planning we use extensive
simulation whenever we introduce or
consider introducing new network
capacity we want to make sure that it is
not going to impact our SL O's
negatively or it's not going to do so in
unexpected ways and as part of this
we've actually evolved our planning
processes so we used to use trended
historical data on outages and expected
failure rates and we'd run some Monte
Carlo type simulations to actually
understand what the potential SLO we'd
expect to see was now we've moved beyond
that a little bit and we're performing
more discrete event analysis these days
so what we do is we classify a whole
batch of different failure types across
the entire network path and we assign
each of them probability curves and
frequency curves of happening blast
radius independency variables we then
push these all together
and run them for a fictional you know 10
20 30 50 years into the future against a
whole different range of network
topologies and what this does is gives
us a reasonably high degree of certainty
that the network we choose and the
additional capacity in locations and
paths that we add into it is going to
meet and maintain and increase the
resilience and the predictability that
we care so much about
this sounds like a lot of bother is it
really worth it the answer is really
clearly yes okay here's an example from
2018 last year we're looking here at two
data centers in our APAC region we have
a number of paths and I've obfuscated
the data here slightly for commercial
reasons on the cables but you can see we
had two cuts to do co2 jewel-case
failure scenarios where we lost paths on
two systems at once and in fact one of
these was what we call a jewel-case
worst failure where we lost one of the
very large pads these are also quite
long enduring events and that's because
in the submarine world the actual
identification of a failure through to
the rectification can take months
you have to permit there's weather
issues the ship may not be available to
go and do the repair it may not find the
cable they may have to remake the repair
now fortunately because of all of that
planning and effort into building a
resilient Network that I talked about
earlier no Google cloud customer and no
Google service was negatively impacted
by these jewel-case failure events okay
things just went on and that's what we
try and aim for we tried very much to
not leave anything to chance when we're
building out this network so now that
we've built it in a resilient manner
it's critical that we operate it
resilient ly as well and there's three
aspects to that that I want to share
with you today the first is Sdn
everywhere it's no secret that we've
operated an SDN network on our core
interred at a-- center campus network
however a couple of years ago we
announced with espresso that we were
pushing Sdn right out to the edge and
that process is effectively finished as
of now
what does this mean well it enables us
to maintain a level of performance and
availability right out to the edge of
the network that's simply not possible
using regular routing approaches and
writing protocols we can optimize our
link utilization at the same time as we
maintain certain business rules quality
of service aspects and priorities it
also offers a lot faster convergence
than traditional protocols like MPLS
running RSVP secondly at the edge of our
network we connect with nearly all
significant network operators and this
allows us to handoff directly and
reliably close to the end user about 99
percent of our traffic so together these
first two points translate to higher
availability better performance through
Google's clouds Network than isn't
available through the Internet at large
but the icing on the cake is always our
sre teams so our site reliability
engineering teams if you've not visited
the sorry lounge yet it's across in the
back corner look for the inflatable
unicorn Google literally wrote the book
on a sari and it's available in the book
shop in the Swank corner we have a
number of network SRE team stations
throughout the world and it's their role
to continually respond and adapt to
network events to improve systems and
processes so that the reliability and
performance of the network continues to
improve over time
it's a classic post mortem culture
something goes wrong we don't blame
people we identify root cause we learn
and we implement approaches and
workarounds to build a resilience and a
performance that only goes one way up
our sre teams are also on hand to give a
second level of support to our customer
facing staff and help on some deep cloud
issues that may may require a little bit
more involvement on the actual network
layer
so together we operate for resilience
across these three levels but our
network your traffic our traffic doesn't
stop at the edge of our network okay
the Internet is a critical part of how
all of us deliver traffic to end-users
to our customers and it will continue to
be so so our commitment to performance
and to reliability and trustworthiness
goes beyond the edge of our network to
the Internet at large now as many of you
know the reality is the Internet is not
a controlled space bad stuff happens
issues like right hijacks are a fact of
life
okay unfortunately a keyboard error by a
small ISP in Africa can really cause
global problems right as maybe some of
you remember from news articles last
year and they hit Google so that's not
great so here's an example we've got a
bad actor
they're doing a couple of things that's
not ideal let's assume it's not
malicious it's just a keyboard mistake
anyone could make it they're gonna
advertise some of Google IP space
towards their peers they're also
advertising some IP space from another
network outdoors the Internet well today
these routes are going to start to
propagate and traffic could go the wrong
way
okay user traffic could end up being
black holes being isolated just bad
things so this is not great and we've
seen this happen too many times
what's Google trying to do about this
okay well firstly we're continually
enhancing it our own monitoring and
filtering capabilities we want to make
sure we can get quicker and better at
identifying these sorts of issues and
responding to them however this is a
community-wide issue and so we are
working with other organizations in
partnership we've joined Manners for
those who not heard of it is the best
acronym in the world manners the
mutually agreed norms for writing
security it is an AI Sox sponsored group
and it's really working to try and
enhance the security of writing on the
Internet so Google has recently joined
and I can announce that shortly we will
start applying routing filters based on
the writing registry irr to all of our
public peering sessions so we want to
slowly encourage other network operators
to up their game in maintaining the
accuracy and veracity of those irr
records now that's great but it's going
to take a little bit of time anything on
the internet takes time hopefully this
will be faster than ipv6 everywhere so
the other thing we're doing is something
called peer lock and so pure lock we
think will give us some short-term
immediate gain and we're gonna work with
about 15 or 20 of our largest peering
partners to effectively agree an
additional level of filtering safety
which will validate not just the
addresses but also the paths that we
wish to receive those addresses form
so together with these two aspects we
believe that a lot of these negative
situations will be blocked it's going to
bring additional valuable protection and
stability not just to Google traffic but
because we're such a large part of the
Internet to the Internet as a whole and
of course because this is the network
that drives and powers your traffic to
customers
it'll help Google cloud customers as
well and overall deliver a better
internet for a cloud that's enough about
our underlying network I'm going to hand
over to my colleague Dave
thank you very much Donald my name is
Dave Dave Phillips I'm a colleague of
Donald's here to talk to you about the
performance we have on the Google
Network I'll do that by talking about
three layers of performance right we'll
talk about the overall network software
and the algorithms that we use you used
to talk to us and we used to talk
between our own services we'll talk
about the physical layer and how that
applies directly to you and gives you
benefit I will talk about the Andromeda
cloud layer so where all of your cloud
services live and the main message I
want you to take away is that really at
every layer of the network every level
of performance there's engineering teams
within Google working to optimize get a
little bit of advantage make things
faster make things more resilience and
big investment all the way through it so
in the last three years we spent 30
billion dollars in infrastructure that's
tree zero and billion would it be
sundar announced this year we're
spending 13 billion so one tree and
again billion would it be so let's start
to look at some of these layers and the
innovation we have at them okay so maybe
starting off let's just give you a
snapshot of the timeline of some of the
innovations we've had and I guess some
of the things you'll maybe notice is
that some of the things in the timeline
show up a few years after we've had them
live for a while so there's stuff that's
on the timeline that you can't see that
you'll see a few years from now somebody
I'll have this presentation and there'll
be stuff there but that's just how it
goes but a lot of the stuff that's
public right now well Donal talked about
Sdn that's a real core of what we do Sdn
is this central software controlled way
of doing things
think about your your modern way of
navigating what Maps when it's got
real-time traffic versus how you used to
use a sat-nav 15 years ago and it was a
fixed map and if everybody went the same
direction it was actually slower right
so that's Sdn with central software
control our first iteration of this was
B 4 this is our massive backbone the
Prine Oliver data centers we then
introduced their Jupiter which is our
massive switching fabric that goes
within our data centers makes all these
tens hundreds of thousands of machines
act together as one great big system
I'm dromeda the network software-defined
virtualization there that you guys use
for building up your cloud an expresso
which Donald mentioned the fourth pillar
which is taking that software-defined
capability all the way out to the edge
other things here my clever
software-defined low or sorry our load
balancer that's been in place at Google
now for maybe more than 10 years taking
in all of our front-end traffic and why
all of these base building block
infrastructures are very important is we
solve these problems at Google to scale
to the level we needed to to be able to
deliver traffic for Google but these are
the same building blocks that are in use
for the cloud products you get to use
these same building blocks I guess I
should hold this instead of putting it
down right ok so we said we talked about
these tree layers let's talk about
performance at the network software
layer so as Donald mentioned we want to
make the internet better as a whole
right so not just ourselves internally
but overall because we make it better
for everybody and everybody adopts these
standards
everything gets faster so let me tell
you about two technologies here I'll
talk about BB or and I'll talk about
quick so let's talk about BB or first ok
so this is an algorithm within or a
manner of implementing congestion
control within TCP so TCP for the
longest time was a loss based from the
late 1980s pretty much been lost based
now that's worked for a long time but
when you talk about modern networks
which typically have high capacity links
but relatively small buffers actually
this is not such a great way of doing it
when TCP algorithms detect loss they can
back off quite sharply and actually
counter intuitively I'm very high
capacity networks sometimes you don't
get such great performance on that so we
need to rethink that from the ground up
beebee or is a way of doing that
BB R stands for bottleneck bandwidth
bottleneck Bonwit round-trip propagation
time it's a fundamentally different way
of looking at congestion control and
what it does is the text actual
congestion a models throughput
end-to-end to be able to optimize rather
than being lost based right gives us a
very very significant advantage there's
a sort of a nice little graphic here
because it's able to detect the actual
congestion rather than reacting very
aggressively to loss you get much
greater throughput when we enable this
on YouTube overall globally we got four
percent greater transmit rate 14 percent
in some countries these are actually big
numbers because that was really highly
optimized to begin with okay now very
easy for you to use that as soon as you
talk from your front ends to your back
ends in Google Cloud you're already
using this as soon as you go to anything
which terminates on the Google side your
sessions from Dan are automatically
using VB or right so you get that so
what you're doing big transitions
transitions and transactions rather back
to Google Google storage or anything
without you using this PD or you're
taking advantage of it you're getting
that throughput
let's change tracks let's talk about
another innovation let's talk about
quick quick is quick quick UDP internet
connections and what this is doing is a
way of optimizing your setup so where
you would have used HTTP and TLS over
TCP okay now when you do that
traditionally with using HTTP using TCP
and TLS over TCP sorry over over TCP
you're typically taken about three
round-trips to get that initial set up
three handshakes for that to happen
what quick if you've already talked
with the server you can begin
transmitting traffic immediately right
so very quick especially for that force
page load when we enable that we're
seeing about 8% faster page load again
these are highly optimized things to
begin with so that's actually a big
number how do you have you enable that
yourselves is on your load balancer
inside the system you just enable quick
very easy to do quick is also very very
good and was designed from the ground up
to multiplex for multiplex streams so
traditionally with TCP you have some
multiplex streams you lose some traffic
all streams are held up with quick it's
just the actual stream that's that's
that's lost the traffic due to streams
are good so also very good for moving
between wireless and mobile networks as
you may be doing here because you have a
connection ID routed on a tuple okay so
again these are ways we're optimizing
things at the fundamental software
algorithm layer to make things faster
let's talk about that second thing I
mentioned which is let's talk about
improvements at the physical layer and
how they manifest to you well so this
graphic here you may have seen some
press about last week this is Arjun on a
transatlantic cable that we just
announced Donal mentioned this so this
is our second private cable we actually
have 13 subsea Cable investments so what
that means for you firstly is that we
we're gonna have that deterministic
capacity available for you when you need
it but a lot of innovation at this layer
so this this this cable here has gone
from Virginia to France uh normally when
you're in a datacenter and you see like
a like a fiber tray or a duct or a
trench you see hundreds of cables or
tellings of fibers right subsea it's
very very different the amount the power
you need to regenerate those signals
means in a typical subsea cable you have
at most maybe six or eight fiber pairs
within that this cable here tonight
cable this uses something called space
division multiplexing it's the first
cable
to do that it means we can reuse some of
the same repeaters from multiple fiber
repairs instead of just one so this
system here this actually has 12 cables
world-first
right it's a lot of innovation at that
level right at the physical layer we
name all of our cables after famous
scientists so Curie Dunant
was the first Nobel Prize winner the
next one will be e on it so think of the
scientists beginning with E you can you
can guess what that will be maybe we can
have a competition I don't actually
genuinely know what the cable will be
called a and B where alphas and betas ok
so linking back to that so why does all
this matter why does having all this
physical infrastructure matter and give
you give you benefit give you tangible
benefit well a good way of showing this
is our premium tier so Donald had a
really really good statistic which is
that 99% of our traffic is being handed
off directly so really meaning that it's
going really all the way across the
internet or across the span between
source and destination on the Google
Network on this very very fast very
high-performance Google Network now our
standards here this is kind of the way
most cloud stuff works most cloud
provider works if you're a relative
percentage so I say a routing person but
I've had to learn to say relative person
so if you're a routing person this is
the difference between cold potato and
hot potato ruling cold potato routing is
you you you take the traffic all the way
on your own network that's a premium to
your hot potato as you hand it up as
soon as possible ok this makes a really
big difference if you have premium to
your enabled you're getting a ride on
the earliest ingress point on the Google
Network and Donald showed you the scale
and all of those locations are coming
all the way across the Google Network to
your compute then all the way back
across the Google Network and then off
if you're doing the standard tier
you're pretty much coming in closest to
your compute and then you're being
handed off back to the internet and
you're taking your chances with the
wider Internet after that now what does
this mean in terms of performance well
it's a big deal don't take my word for
it I actually work for Google I'm gonna
tell you it's great but look at the look
at the actual external folks that test
this stuff
this is sue Texas this is actually a
pull this data just from last month the
graph doesn't actually start at zero
that starts at trace you're gone you
talked about 1.9 X greater throughput
going directly across that network as
opposed to going across and taking your
chances with the wider Internet and
that's kind of what you would expect if
we build this really really high
performance network with all these
fibers and all this cable and all this
reach you're gonna get much better
performance so that's the premium tier
now very easy for you to enable that
simply inside your console on your V pcs
you're just going to enable premium tier
you don't need to go messing all this
fancy routing and that's a big message
here that we're able to make all of this
technology very very easy for you to
access it's very complex RM to make it
all work I actually work the networking
for the last 10 years before I came over
to product right but in terms of how it
works for you guys as customers it's
very very easy for you to access this
and turn it on so let me just put three
of those products together as an example
let's talk about that premium networking
let's talk about V PC and let's talk
about global load balancing ok V PC is
your virtual private cloud I'll talk
about that a little bit later but
essentially this is your main network
construct that you build one of the
first things that you've built here's
something to know is that that that is
inherently a global construct right you
might use it on a regional basis
initially but that's inherently a global
construct then let's talk about global
load balancing when you enable this
global load balancing at Google what we
do so we give your service a virtual IP
address but then instead of having a
play around with DNS or doing anything
like that we do
much better leg which is we do any cos
so from all of our edge pops and our
extensive edge infrastructure we will
any cast out that address meaning that
that same address is advertised in all
these different regions meaning that you
will be pulled in at the most proximate
location on our global network right so
here's an example we have Maya in
California she is pulled in directly to
the US West which is on the west coast
we have Bob in London going to the same
address which you view Maps your primary
DNS a record and he's been sucked in
into the London site so for very fast
local performance and then you have Shan
and Singapore again using the same ip
address DNS going into the Singapore pop
there that's what global load balancing
does now because that BPC is also global
it's able to do this very clever stuff
like know if certain aspects of your
system are overloaded it can
automatically redirect to order is an
overflow right so very very clever I'm
very very easy for you to use the power
of this enormous network turning it on
like that let's take this diagram here
and let's imagine we rewind it a bit
okay so I don't have an animation or
anything but let's just pretend we're
not at a stage where we have US Europe
and Asia let's just say we've just set
up just to begin with we've just set up
with a few VMs on the west coast okay so
what I can do turn that on do this
global load balancing set up my DP my V
PC and what's happening there is well
just all of the traffic is being sucked
into the West Coast right then what I
decide is I'm really growing here I
could really use a presence in Europe or
the East Coast or wherever so I set up
in Europe now because the V PC is global
because global load balancing is global
just by setting up in Europe
automatically all that European traffic
or all the traffic próxima that region
is being pulled in there
and then similarly with the quilt in
Asia so very easy to make use of this
without very advanced knowledge of the
underlying infrastructure all right
the other pillar I wanted to talk about
is performance at the Andromeda lair so
this this is the network virtualization
layer that all of this stuff works
within okay so this is this this layer
on top of air infrastructure that's
gonna give you that performance and
functional isolation where your your
your infrastructure lives okay
let's first talk about this idea of the
V PC or a virtual private cloud this is
the basic building block of your your
infrastructure so this is what you what
you define on what you could think about
there's something similar to a network
you set up in your data center this is
your own little private slice of the
cloud and a good thing about this as
firstly as I said it's not region locked
its global now if you have a situation
where you're in financial services are
medical and you need your stuff
contained within a region yes absolutely
we can do that as well but the concept
itself is inherently not something you
need to define in each region
replicating that config you can define
it once you also don't need a B PC for
every project you can do this idea of a
shared V PC where you've got a a
services B PC and then your host host
projects off of that it's a very easy
way to maintain one common security
model one common administrative model
all of your traffic within that B PC is
very very secure it's not touching the
public network at the public Internet
Alice Donnell said you have all those
134 plus points at which you can
interconnect okay so common common
overall model using this V PC is the
base networking block Oh
so this is what it does this is one
Andromeda does it essentially takes all
of our huge infrastructure all those
data sent there's all those fibers all
those pops and chops it up so that you
have your own slice of it it provides
that security and that functional and
performance isolation so here we can see
we've got the the green customer yellow
customer and the red customer they're
all using ten space addresses but that
doesn't matter because they're all
completely isolated and all working
independently within this Andromeda
layer using our infrastructure okay so
how does it work well in terms of what
we do is we push a lot of the networking
all the way to the hosts in fact we do
that in userspace
we push it all the way down to the users
space why do we do that well 4c is very
secure the data plane is not running in
route secondly it's it's a very low
footprint so we can really test it close
it very small surface for any kind of
security vulnerabilities very high
performance and a single processor we're
getting three billion packets per second
for coprocessors then we'll do more more
more more advanced packet rewriting and
things like that we're fast path to a
single processor gives us this very very
high performance without needing to rely
on any ethics or any specific hardware
allows us to iterate very quickly allows
us to do hitless upgrades allows us to
do live migrations allows us to
continually innovate and push push
features
this is the overall architecture itself
the control plan itself was built as a
hierarchy you have a cluster cloud
cluster manager you don't have a fabric
management layer you down at the open
flow layer which we push the
configuration down to on an SDN level so
fully replicated fully charted across
zones across regions and by using that
Sdn or by pushing the configuration down
into the fabric that allows us to really
do this horizontal scaling and that's a
very let's think about it like this
think about our internal load balancer
right now we have all these different
load balancers we talked about the
global load balancer earlier I'm now
talking about an internal load balancer
within your slice of the data center
actually how you normally implement that
is you have a dedicated box or a
dedicated machine that does that or a
dedicated VM that does that we don't
it's all existing within the switch
fabric so it means there's no middle box
there's no choke point that's
configuration pushed out into the Sdn
layer which gives you that load
balancing capability it gives you this
near infinite scaling this is an idea of
some of the level of performance we've
gotten one Andromeda over the years so
one of the main things we tried to look
at is the cycles per byte in terms of
transmitting traffic and as we've gone
through the various iterations there
we've had very very significant levels
of improvement up to 16x and up to 50/50
boy per cycle improvement the biggest
jump was to Andromeda to 0 when we put
most everything into the guest's layer
bypassing the host and Rambla to 1 we
got rid of the last read and Andromeda
to 2 we added a memory copying and we
continue to innovate very aggressively
just since we talked to you last at the
last cloud next let's see we've gotten
we've introduced LPM longest prefix
matching caches per machine so for
internet heavy workloads that makes a
big difference
our Hermes system for network
configuration
pushes is now twice as fast about 15
seconds to push the network configuring
oh we've dealt with 2018 was there was a
lot of very very large CPU issues
Spectre mind-meld etc we were able to
deal with those very very easily in the
background from you a lot of scaling in
our load balancers particularly using
something called hoverboards so we're
able to scale those load balancers quite
a lot further than we where I look one
thing that all these improvements are
leading to higher performance devices
for you higher performance services so
up next here we'll be announcing the 32
gigabit per second VMS limit before this
was 16 gig per second going all the way
up to 32 now in your skylake machine
that's in all regions with 16 V CPUs you
get all the way up to 32 and that
network is going to give you that
performance up to a hundred gigs energy
GPU level machines to going into alpha
so if you have one of these high end GPU
machines 100 gig for that talks your
account rep now let's look at how we
manage and monitor all of those
solutions I'll hand you over to my
colleague Martha
my name is Monza okay here we go my name
is Melissa and I'm going to talk to you
about how we monitor our network you
heard from Donald earlier about how we
build our global network for resilience
and you heard from Dave about our
investments and innovations to be able
to drive for better performance and I'll
talk to you about how we monitor our
internal infrastructure to begin with
where Google kind of has a way of
monitoring our network at various levels
right in starting from interest though
and Interzone intervie m to the edge and
so on but we'll also talk through how we
think about monitoring how our end-users
experience the services that get
deployed and Google Cloud and then we'll
also go through how we use all these
metrics that get generated to be able to
optimize our service delivery paths to
our end customers and plan for the
future as well so with that let's get
started every machine on the Google
network is actually a part of an
overarching monitoring infrastructure we
collect near real-time logs on each of
these hosts that we have so it includes
metrics like RTT and throughput and this
does not require any additional software
to get installed on any of the hosts so
it comes at no additional performance
impact to you what this enables us to do
is it enables us to monitor and get
visibility into our infrastructure at
various levels we can get metrics at the
VPC in network as a whole or for a
specific subnet or drill down all the
way to a specific VM instance or a
virtual interface apart from this
collection infrastructure we've also
deployed probes extensively across our
network and this provides us with
additional visibility into things like
packet loss latency and various other
metrics we also googles overall built a
network where
the network and the horse actually
played well together to be able to
optimize for performance we built this
centralized bandwidth allocation
algorithm that's able to actually
enforce policy at the host level and all
of this works at the scale of Google van
for those of you who are interested in
learning more about that check out the
publication that we have on called
bandwidth enforcer and you should be
able to get to know more about that
okay moving forward like I mentioned
let's talk a little bit more about how
we think about understanding how our
end-users experience services that get
deployed on Google cloud because through
an end-user point of view they don't
really care where the network issues are
right it might be at the Google end or
external to our network but they just
want things to work soviet google need
to kind of think about it more
proactively to understand where the
issue lies and work with our partners
proactively to be able to manage those
issues so we've built an infrastructure
and technology where we are able to
understand connectivity issues from end
users coming into Google Network itself
and be able to attribute that
specifically to where that issue lies be
it at Google's end or outside of
Google's network and that enables us to
work with the partners and minimize and
the impact to end-users be it our end
users or our cloud customers and users
and as you can imagine a lot of more we
serve about a billion plus users with
this network and they are dispersed
geography at least we collecting all of
these metrics from all corners of the
Internet so what do we use his metrics
for first and foremost you've built
models to be able to detect an alert
about fault conditions or near fault
conditions and then we take all this
data to be able to provide a feedback
loop and optimize our service delivery
paths to our customers
and we also then take this data to be
able to minimize the time we spend on
troubleshooting and mitigating issues
and over a longer time we use collect
but these patterns and understand these
patterns to be able to plan for the
future
and understand to be able to plan or
traffic growth and capacity as we go
forward so we talked about the metrics
that we collect we talked about how we
use them but let's talk a little bit
about how we measure them these metrics
over the past few years as platform
density has increased to kind of go to
include thousands of physical interfaces
and as the deployments themselves have
changed we have started to collect
metrics that the number of metrics are
actually grown exponentially right so
traditional pull based methods like SNMP
and syslog don't really work much
anymore for example a typical
dynamically provisioned app could have
been spun up I served its purpose and
been shut down well within a five minute
time frame time span that kind of phase
including the SNMP polling cycle so that
makes our network operators run blind so
we needed a better solution so what we
did was worked with industry leaders
like arrestor cisco juniper to be able
to advance the state of the art in
device monitoring we have been working
to build and standardize streaming
telemetry as a replacement for SNMP and
syslog like architectures and streaming
telemetry what it does which provides a
high fidelity data near real-time
performance to be able to help us
optimize for our traffic parts and
provide more real time performance
metrics
we also work with ISPs worldwide to be
able to provide them with near real-time
performance measurements Google
maintains a global peering footprint
with a generally open peering policy and
we provide access to the Google ISP
portal to operators who share the direct
network edge relationship with us with
this is P portal
what are operators able to do as they
are able to get insights about how
exactly Google sending traffic and why
that's the case to those specific
partners how we together can grow and
specific insights into actionable
metrics actually into how to improve
delivery quality and performance and
things like that so what you see here is
actually a part of snapshot of our
Google eyes before whoo
and you can see that we do what we
provide is basically ingress and egress
traffic breakdowns performance metrics
like RTT throughput even video quality
and all the way go down to providing our
partners with capabilities to be able to
actually predict what the traffic growth
looks like so we've also been we also
have ongoing investments on the product
we won't very want to share more and
more of these metrics with our and with
our cloud customers
I've talked through a few of these
products today the first one of them is
load balancer telemetry so load balancer
monitoring helps you helps you get
visibility into your internet facing
applications and perform Diagnostics
around that it includes measurements
like number of connections latency for
both the front end and the back end and
throughput let's talk about VP CA
furlongs think of PPC flow logs as
equivalent to net flow for TCP
environments we are able to monitor
everything that comes in and out of the
compute right it's it's near real time
without any performance impact to you
when you turn these on in your TCP
environments and you can again measure
things at the VP C Network level or
drill down all the way to the VM
instance level five all logs
so basically firewall logs help you to
get visibility into every connection
attempt against the firewall rules that
had logging enabled so you'll be able to
audit or perform forensics on all the
connections that got denied or allowed
over a longer period of time to figure
out patterns and you can consume all of
this information in stag driver or
export it to some of the third party
tools that you may have deployed today
in your environments we have
integrations with some of the major
partners including Splunk sumo logic and
many more you can go check those out so
in summary you heard about our wrestling
Network you heard about the innovations
or investments here and how we monitor
it here are a few of the other
networking sessions that you might be
interested in that are relevant that are
going to take place over the next few
days and a link to our networking blog
in case you're interested in following
us for any of the future announcements
in the space
[Music]